[Música]
hola que tal bueno en esta plática
walter platicarles un poco sobre la
sustentabilidad porque la
sustentabilidad es algo así como de los
charolastras y la neta es y china- pero
inalcanzable a veces vamos a conocer un
poco más a detalle de cuál es mi
expectativa o cuál es mi realidad en la
que vivo a través de la palabra
sustentabilidad entonces primero la
contabilidad es un sueño guajiro para
eso tenemos que analizar qué es lo que
está causando los problemas actuales en
la humanidad esos problemas lo estamos
causando tú que me estás viendo esto a
través de una plataforma digital que
consume internet y yo que estoy en esta
oficina que consume electricidad
entonces realmente uno de los problemas
que tenemos o por qué tenemos tanta
contaminación realmente es porque
existimos que al existir tenemos que
consumir tenemos que usar tenemos que
gastar y todo eso tiene que seguir de
algún lado y ese lado la verdad es que
se sigue agotando día con día y es el
principal problema que tenemos con la
palabra rentabilidad que es
sustentabilidad y rentabilidad es poder
usar algo yo pero no usarlo de tal
manera que mis hijos y mis nietos y sus
nietos no alcancen a usarlo con la
palabra su estabilidad es más o menos
como un sueño guajiro que podemos hacer
para que los recursos que tenemos no nos
agotemos completamente primeramente el
el hilo negro muchas veces buscamos los
reportes de la onu de la unicef que
vemos lo que dice harvard pero esto es
como una dieta yo sé porque tengo un
sobrepeso y sé cómo solucionarlo a veces
necesito que note luego me diga deja de
comer pizza deje de tomar cerveza la
contabilidad es algo muy parecido a esto
sabemos que lo que hacemos en el día a
día que podríamos mejorar pero a veces
queremos encontrarles siempre por
ejemplo he escuchado mucho últimamente
la electrificación del transporte
electrificar nuestro medio de transporte
pero esto la solución y tengo hacer esta
pregunta para que vea si la solución o
no o bien se es un poquito más que es
mejor caminar hacia el trabajo movernos
en una bicicleta el trabajo tener un
vehículo y usarlo relativamente pocos
kilómetros porque llevo cerca del
trabajo o comprarme un tesla que es un
carro eléctrico hablamos que la solución
al transporte va a ser la
electrificación del transporte pero hay
que recordar que esa electricidad tiene
que salir de algún lado que la batería
de litio contamina que el vehículo al
hacerlo usa metal ese metal tiene que
fundirse tiene que extraerse tiene que
explotar se y son muchísimas cosas que
se nos olvidan cuando hablamos a qué
fáciles electrificar y qué más carros
eléctricos no también tiene sus retos
entonces realmente que es mejor por lo
mejor sería no usar no usar significa
podernos mover a pie poder ser una
bicicleta o hasta a veces que es mejor
un carro con pocos kilómetros o un carro
eléctrico es mejor sinceramente tener un
spark y usarlo 10 20 kilómetros a la
semana tienen un tesla y usarlo 300 400
kilómetros a la semana porque al final
también esa electricidad sale de algún
lado
luego las famosas fuentes renovables hoy
es que yo soy sustentable porque está en
el panel es en mi casa
realmente hay que entender cómo funciona
electricidad y saber qué es el instalar
paneles realmente estoy ayudando tanto
al medio ambiente como ayudo a mi
bolsillo porque a veces confundimos las
dos cosas instalamos paneles porque son
pues sustentables económicamente y me
convienen y se nos olvidan realmente la
parte de la rentabilidad ecológica
los paneles tienen que transportarse
desde china esto consume pues el flete
el camión el buque tiene que explotar si
el silicio tiene que eliminarse el
silicio tiene que pasar por muchísimas
etapas que son energéticamente
intensivas pero también cuando uso
energía renovable si es cierto dejo de
usar energía fósil pero en la noche
vuelvo a usar energía fósil que a veces
contamina más que la energía que deje de
usar durante el día pues depende mucho
también si uso mi energía renovable pero
aparte dejó de consumir cosas en mi casa
pues es mucho mejor a solamente instale
paneles y por eso yo soy renovable y voy
a poner mi aire a 18 grados y dormir
como pingüino en verano yo soy
muchísimas cosas que llevan la
sustentabilidad y no solamente el meter
paneles tengo que dejar de consumir
energía fósil
pero también cuando dejó de consumir
energía fósil durante el día por los
paneles dejó de usar energía que viene
de ciclos combinados los ciclos
combinados ya usan energía fósil pero de
manera muy eficiente y si en la tarde
porque tengo paneles solares y no me
cuesta la luz empiezo de mandar mucha
electricidad de la red eléctrica pues
voy a usar energía que se usa a través
de combustóleos que es en otros ciclos
que no son tan eficientes como los
ciclos que tenemos durante el día
entonces la sustentabilidad también con
las fuentes renovables no es lo que a
veces nos han platicado o lo que creemos
entonces que se puede hacer pues la
verdad es que es un tema que es muy
difícil ponerse acuerdo porque tiene que
ver con lo que nos gusta en nuestro
estilo de vida es decir usar celulares
nuevos relojes computadoras salir de
fiesta viaja en avión eso significa que
estamos condenados que ya mejor no
hacemos nada y nos tiramos pues no
realmente la sustentabilidad la vamos a
lograr a través de muchísimo esfuerzo y
muchísimo trabajo y hablamos entonces de
los carros eléctricos si todos cambiamos
de golpe de tener ningún correo
eléctrico a todos los carros eléctricos
usada en la torre el sistema eléctrico
nacional porque la demanda va a ser
altísima imagínense que todas las
gasolineras ya no se usaran y ahora van
a ser electrolineras la cantidad energía
que sacáramos de la red tuviéramos
congestiones en las redes eléctricas no
tuviéramos suficiente generación para
abastecer todo esto y se elevaría
muchísimo el consumo electricidad y el
costo de la electricidad por vender
entonces así que cambiamos a carros
eléctricos y tenemos una solución
realmente si cambiamos a carros
eléctricos tenemos un problema que
también tendremos que solucionar y si
todos ponemos paneles solares en
nuestras casas qué maravilloso qué
bonito digo qué buen negocio para mí
pero a final de cuentas se va a acabar
lo que va a ser la energía fósil pues no
porque en la tarde que nos quedemos sin
paneles solares o que se acaba el sol
tendrá que arrancar plantas de
generación y son plantas de generación
que tienen que arrancar muy rápido pues
vamos a quitar las plantas de generación
que funcionan ahorita muy eficiente como
ciclos combinados como nucleares a veces
hasta las carboeléctricas son mejores
que las plantas que pueden ser con
combustóleo
entonces todos ponemos paneles solares
tenemos ahora un problema de generación
que nos puede traer una red eléctrica no
sustentable y no estable y lo malo es
que nos gusta la electricidad cuando
aprendemos el switch y se prende el foco
entonces pues no es tan fácil este tema
y si tuviéramos todo con el hubble y acá
pues tenemos muchísima energía durante
la noche que es cuando más soy el viento
y durante el día tuviéramos casi nada no
tuviéramos electricidad constante y nos
gusta mucho la electricidad cuando
queremos queremos poder prender la tele
y cuando está el partido y no cuando
tengo electricidad o quiero poner mi
cafetera cuando me levanto y en una
tarde que tengo energía solar entonces
bien que sea una adaptación esto y si
usaremos como dicen ahora la
hidroeléctrica pues hay que recordar que
nuestro país pasa por periodos de sequía
muy grandes y si sacamos todo el agua de
las presas nos vamos a quedar sin agua
en las presas y el principal objetivo de
las presas pues va a ser primero consumo
humano segundo evitar inundaciones y el
tercero pues va a ser generar
electricidad y si cambiamos el orden
tendremos mucha electricidad
unos meses pero después nos vamos a
quedar sin agua para riego y sin agua
para consumo humano entonces tampoco
podemos usar todo de las fuentes
hidroeléctricas como nos quieren
proponer entonces hoy por hoy las
renovables no pueden estar solas pero
ojo yo te estoy hablando del día de hoy
por eso hablamos de una transición
energética e ir cambiando poco a poco en
nuestro estilo de vida actual donde no
puede ser solamente solar pues no puede
ser solamente eólico pues no puede ser
solamente hidroeléctrica a un proceso
que se llama una transición energética
vamos a ir cambiando poco a poco y vamos
a ir aprendiendo a solucionar estos
problemas así como los coches eléctricos
no vamos a cambiar todos de golpe vamos
a estarlo haciendo poco a poco de una
manera en que la red pueda aguantar pero
también tiene que cambiar cosas como
nuestro estilo de vida vivir más cerca
donde trabajamos consumir cosas más
locales y no tenerlas que traer desde
china porque están mucho más baratas
ustedes tienen que ser una integración
múltiple energías cuando decíamos que
los teros eléctricos no van a ser la
solución la verdad es que no pro energía
solar tampoco genera durante la noche
pero si yo veo a más de puede ir sumando
que los carros eléctricos y la energía
solar se complementan porque cuando yo
tengo mucho energía solar mis causa
eléctricos se pueden cargar se van a
cargar de la energía solar y cuando
tengan poca energía los carros
eléctricos también pueden soltar
energías en la red
entonces empieza a sumar diferentes
actores electrificación de los vehículos
incorporación de renovables pero también
por ejemplo la energía eólica funciona
mejor la noche que en el día desde el
complemento energía solar con energía
eólica con la palabra sustentabilidad
empieza a tener sentido no poseer
solamente eólico puede ser solamente
solar pero también la gas también puede
usar plantas de gas usando las de la
manera más eficiente y las más
psicológicas posibles si tomamos las
fortalezas de cada una cada tecnología y
cada problema podemos hacer que los
carros eléctricos se creen con energía
solar y luego suelten energía en la
noche y esto van a ser las redes
inteligentes también que tu casa
estoy acondicionado en firma en la casa
con tengo un exceso de electricidad y
cuando llegues pues a la mejor y está
fría y no consuma tanta electricidad
de la red entonces todo esto vamos a
funcionar lo como un buffer de energía
vamos a aprender a coordinar nuestra
vida hacia las fuentes renovables que
tenemos y no al revés que estamos
acostumbrados a prender el switch de la
electricidad pero qué te parece si era
mejor el carro eléctrico se va a cargar
cuando haya mucha gran energía solar y
como hay mucha energía solar por oferta
y demanda pues va a ser más barata que
la tarde yo puedo escoger y decirle a mi
carro oye carga te cuando cueste 50
centavos el kilo watt hora y si llega a
costar más de dos pesos vende y estas
son las redes inteligentes es una mezcla
variada o tenemos diferentes factores
que nos van a ir contribuir cada uno en
el desarrollo de la sustentabilidad de
nosotros
pero pues a qué costo va a ser esto pero
va a ser un costo de sacrificio en
investigación a prueba y error apagones
hay que tener un poco de paciencia en
este juego porque la verdad es que nadie
está logrando una comunidad 100%
sustentable y así trabajando día con día
en tener nuestro granito de arena en
nuestros mezclas admitiendo los costos
reales y es decir si está barata energía
solar cargo prendo mi cafetera y si está
caro pues mejor de jose electricidad a
la gente que si realmente la ocupa
porque la energía solar sola pues
requiere grandes cantidades de silicio
grandes minas y tampoco es tan
sustentable si la veo así la eólica
puede dañar el medio ambiente la vida
silvestre la hidráulica cuando sube el
nivel de la presa las plantas que quedan
atrapadas se van a llegar un proceso de
putrefacción que van a generar gas
metano y el metano es más contaminante
todavía que el co2 entonces por sí solas
ninguna es tan sustentable lo que
tenemos que lograr es reducir el consumo
no hay una respuesta absoluta y la
verdad es que nuestro estilo de vida
cuesta por eso tengo que consumir cada
vez menos caminar más es mejor caminar
que compran un tesla comprar productos
locales que no hayan viajado tanto que
no hayan estado tan refrigerados en que
en el frío consume muchísima
electricidad y pues aceptar que la única
manera de lograr la sustentabilidad es
cambiando y pues enfocando nuestras
acciones a tener una fuente energética
mucho más variable no significa
incorporar la energía solar la eólica la
hidroeléctrica todas con los errores que
nos va a costar lograr esto porque
tampoco es tan fácil tendremos apagones
intermitencias tendremos desastres a la
mejor en la red pero la incorporación de
las renovables aprender cómo funcionan
nos van a permitir junto con los carros
eléctricos la automatización de las
redes nos van a permitir un mundo más
sustentable aunque alcanzarlo y lograrlo
no sea tan
méxico actualmente está en micros y jala
muy rara porque avanzamos hacia enfrente
a la mejor no de la manera correcta
avanzamos enfrente por un poquito hacia
el lado no como deberíamos con la
reforma energética hubo cambios muy
buenos pero también quedó muy bien
conclusa si le dejó mucha carga a las
tradicionales y las renovables es muy
agusto produzco ahora que produzco y
después no me preocupo cómo estabilizar
la red y la verdad que la red está
parada con alfileres tiene que estar
siempre siempre precisa cualquier
movimiento fuera de 60 hertz se saben
las plantas entre las protecciones y no
es tan fácil controlarla
el detalle es curita queremos dar ahora
sido un paso completamente hacia atrás
pero 30-40 años a donde había una sola
generación y se le daba prioridad a lo
que estaba barato y ahorita barato
méxico tiene lo que es el combustóleo no
lo que es más eficiente lo que cuesta
menos realmente porque más barato en la
solar del combustóleo la solar no tiene
un costo de generación tiene un coste de
mantenimiento y un capex muy alto pero
el coste de combustible pues es cero y
el cambio la el combustóleo pues es la
verdad muy contaminante pero méxico
tiene muchísimo orita les quiere volver
usarlo
el poco avance que teníamos hacia
enfrente la sustentabilidad en la red
eléctrica que no contamine tanto pues
estamos yendo hacia atrás y es
importante nosotros como mexicanos pues
defender esto y apoyar que con las
renovables a la mejor experimentamos
apagones pero es importante generar el
capital humano con conocimiento
tecnificado para saber cómo solucionarlo
porque si cambiamos en 20 años y damos
otra vez que vamos dar ese paso tan
grande en 20 años más pues el problema
es que tendremos gente no capaz
tendremos que otra vez de importar
capital humano importar conocimiento
importante qno logías esto yo creo que
es una relación horita que tenemos que
seguir explotando entre gobierno
iniciativa privada y centros de
investigación informar capital humano
muy bien capacitado en el tema las
energía renovarse
tres secciones que puede ser para
disminuir tu huella de carbono o impacto
sustentabilidad la primera es camina más
lo primero es dejar de usar el automóvil
porque aparte nos conviene bajamos un
poco la pancita gastamos menos y
contaminamos menos pues lo primero es
dejar de usar lo que contamina mucho que
se va no solamente en eso también los
aires acondicionados oye si me ha
condicionado es muy viejo pues lo cambio
por uno más nuevo que consuma menos pero
también oye y si duermo con un poco
menos de frío también subir un poco los
grados en verano o bajar los grados en
invierno pues también ayuda muchísimo
también ponemos un suéter citó extra o
quitarnos un poco de ropa va a ayudar
muchísimo porque dejamos de consumir
energía
la otra es tratar de consumir local
porque porque el campo a lo mejor el
campo el que le compras pues está cerca
de tu casa y no viene desde otro país de
otro lugar que hay que tomar en cuenta a
veces impresiona las botellas de vino
español la botella que te cuesta 40
pesos y dices ai wei el vidrio el
transporte la distribución se ha dejado
el precio el precio energético
una botella de donde sale entonces es
importante consumir local consumir menos
y sobre todo pues tomar un granito arena
y ser consciente de nosotros al
cualquier acción de compra o de comida
por ejemplo la carne roja es deliciosa
yo soy carnívoro pues total pero a veces
la carne roja tiene sus problemas y esos
problemas son que las vacas por tener un
estómago o cuatro estómagos en su
digestión generan muchísimo gas metano y
contaminan mucho más que el co2 una
planta eléctrica situamos el volumen más
el excremento se sigue fermentado y sin
generando metano entonces la carne roja
tiene el la carne frío muy
energéticamente consumidora y sobre todo
también el ganado consume mucho y mucho
grano que ese grano en vez de usarse
para humanos se está usando para el
ganado y tampoco es lo idóneo entonces
serían las tres acciones que diría que
puedes hacer consumir menos cambiar de
productos consumir local y dejar de
consumir carnes rojas y un gran impacto
tendrías en el medio ambiente muchas
gracias
bien
[Música]